des images de ce matin au palais de
justice de saint jérôme guy turcotte
vous le voyez complet gris qui a donc
obligatoirement assisté au début de ce
procès au début c'est le choix des jurés
on va tenter de poser les questions de
base concernant ce procès dans ce
deuxième procès qui commence j'ai invité
bertrand st-arnaud vous le connaissez
ex-ministre de la justice avocats bien
sûr richard dubé avocat criminaliste
messieurs bonsoir à vous première
question pourquoi nous assistons un
deuxième procès sur cette arme
essentielle ment parce qu'on se rappelle
tous du premier procès en 2011 le
verdict en était un de
non-responsabilité criminelle pour
troubles mentaux
mais suite à ce verdict là la poursuite
a décidé d'aller en appel donc elle est
allée en appel devant la cour d'appel du
québec qui en 2013 ordonné un nouveau
procès principalement en disant que le
juge lors de ses directives au jury à la
toute fin du procès juste avant les
délibérations le juge explique toujours
les grandes questions de droit c'est
quoi un meurtre c'est quoi les troubles
mentaux
c'est quoi l'intoxication volontaire le
jeu à ce moment là selon la cour d'appel
au fait une erreur dans ses directives
une erreur suffisamment grave pour
ordonner un nouveau procès la défense a
tenté d'aller en appel à la cour suprême
du canada
mais comme 3 julie trois juges de la
cour d'appel étaient unanimes dans leurs
décisions ça connaît la permission de la
cour suprême du canada pour aller en
appel la cour suprême a refusé cette
permission refusé d'entendre la cause
et donc c'est la cause le jugement la
cour d'appel qui finale qui ordonne un
nouveau procès qui a commencé ce matin m
dubé on efface complètement le tableau
on repart à zéro comme ce n'est pas une
premier procès c'est toujours comme ça
après un jugement d'appel qui casse un
verdict les lédoniens de les mêmes qu'au
départ en fait c'est toujours la même
chose ne passe et recommence comme il
était donc rien qui n'a été dit
évidemment à l'intérieur de la cour ne
peut être utilisé ce qui a été dit aux
policiers par monsieur de surcote la
couronne devra redéposer preuve par
preuve devant les jurés ça c'est la
reprise intégrale du premier procès et
avec en fait la preuve la poursuite
presse d'être à peu près une autre
séquence essentiellement les policiers
sont arrivés sur les lieux les
pathologistes etc
par la suite pendant quatre ans et un
deuxième procès il peut quand même y
avoir des changements de témoin ce qu'il
y aura de nouveaux experts par exemple
lors de la preuve la défense lors de la
contre eux preuve on se rappelle le
monsieur juan les plus vieux d'entre
d'entre nous se rappelle il ya 25 ans la
cause de jules père qui était un rythme
un réalisateur il sait radio canada
accusé du meurtre de sa conjointe
premier procès il décide de ne pas
témoigner il est trouvé coupable de
meurtre et la cour d'appel ordonne un
nouveau procès de trois ans plus tard
cette fois ci il décide de témoigner
contrairement au premier procès ce
changement de stratégie cette fois et
les textes et donc il peut y avoir quand
même des changements quant aux témoins
qui seront entendus à parler de faire ce
qui est en jeu ici dont le procès ce que
l'état mental de monsieur turcotte à
l'époque des événements et a aussi
influencé par l'alcool apparemment et c6
que la cour d'appel a décidé suite au
jugement de cour suprême ultérieurement
rendue ce qu'on ne peut pas additionner
ces deux facteurs n'a pas décidé si une
suite sur quatre avait des tas mentales
altérées à ce point pour ne pas faire la
différence entre le bien et le mal
alors aujourd'hui les avocats de la
défense ont 11,7 7,7 stratégies à
développer à l'effet que est ce qu'on va
faire la même défense ce qui va voir ce
qu'on va en donner
certains éléments de la défense du
premier procès c'est pour cette raison
un nouvel aspect après alosi par étapes
autre question qu'on se pose comment
peut-on vraiment trouver des jurés
impartiaux qui ne se sont pas déjà fait
une opinion sur cette affaire là la
pratique est la suivante quand les
juristes même très important la cas les
jurés à lille de candidat juré le jus
les informe du quart et a sacré de
l'exercice et on s'aperçoit rapidement
que les jurés se conforment sont très
très concerné par les aspects importants
de stade mais ici comme dans le premier
procès il ya vu une couverture énorme de
cette affaire et les premiers jurés ont
rendu un verdict surprenant pour la
population dans un contexte où on
s'attendait peut-être une condamnation
et on a vu qu'un verdict que je pourrais
travailler en dehors de la vindicte
populaire
donc si possible oui c'est aussi tout à
fait possible et est en fait la semaine
prochaine qu'on va arriver parce que
cette semaine seulement les extensions
le ceux qui ne veulent pas
agir comme juré mais à partir de semaine
prochaine quand on va faire la véritable
sélection du jury
vraisemblablement que dans une cause
médiatisés comme celle ci on va poser
quelques questions aux candidats jury
quand ils vont s'avancer premièrement ce
que vous avez entendu parler de la
sphère surcote probablement la plupart
ont dit leur deuxième mère c'est
toujours surprenant dans mon coin
seulement en deuxième question ce que
vous faites une opinion sur cette
affaire hélas le cas du jury va répondre
et s'ils répondent oui la troisième et
dernière question qui va lui être posées
est-ce que vous êtes capable de mettre
de côté l'opinion quand vous êtes fait
pour juger seulement sur la preuve est
présenté dans cette salle de cofor et en
fonction des réponses que les candidats
auront beau redonner à ces trois
questions
les deux parties vont décider si oui ou
non ils acceptent ces candidats jurés
parce que richard qui a fait beaucoup de
procès devant jury le sait très bien
chaque parti a la possibilité de récuser
avec raison glock pour cause ou sans
raison c'est-à-dire péremptoirement les
cas d'injures et pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux la en bout de ligne on
écoute les réponses à ces questions pour
trouver effectivement des jurés qui
seront complètement impartiaux dernière
question vous l'avez effleuré un peu
tout à l'heure mais c'est les mêmes
accusations
est-ce qu'on s'attend à la même défense
personnellement je pense
qu'effectivement la question centrale
demeure la même c'est quoi la question
centrale au dernier procès il a été
admis que monsieur turcotte a causé la
mort de ses enfants et je pense que ça
va être encore le peu que je pense que
cette admission votre patience pour moi
non alors la question c'est quoi quel
était l'état d'esprit l'état mental de
monsieur turcotte lors de l'événement et
tout dépend alors c'est la question
centrale est tout dépendant de la
réponse qu'on donne à cette question là
mais il ya un verdict de murs mais un
verdict d'homicide involontaire ou un
verdict comme la première fois de
non-responsabilité criminelle pour
troubles mentaux
alors c'est le centre du débat quel
était l'état d'esprit l'état mental de
monsieur turcotte au moment de causer la
mort de si la même défense que l'avocat
de la défense vont reproduire ce qu'ils
aux halles crash du manthey la cour
d'appel à savoir que ce qui est
fondamental c'est l'état mental de
l'accusé
indépendamment de
de l'alcool et de son effet ils ont
plaidé dans ce sens doit plus haut
certains croient même chose mais c'est
ce roi qu'au niveau de la stratégie
compte tenu de la décision de la cour
d'appel il ya deux ans car qui est qui
redonne un nouveau procès même si la
question des centrales demeurent la même
dans la stratégie dans les témoins qui
seront appelés dans les questions qui
seront posées chaque parti va devoir se
positionner parce que la cour d'appel a
donné un certain cave que le jeu je vois
respecté dans cette directive
alors les parties vont certainement bon
on est obligé je vous donne 30 secondes
chacun est ce qu'on va pas se retrouver
encore une fois devant une bataille
d'expertisé et d'experts des psychiatres
tout à fait c'est une cause d'experts
c'est eux qui peuvent instruire les
jurés sur l'état médical de lézardrieux
et séquence est fondamental dans cette
affaire là c'est ce qui va faire tout à
fait d'accord c'est la question la
question est celle que je vous
mentionnais tantôt et donc pour répondre
à cette question là ça prend des experts
il y aura vraisemblablement des experts
en défense et éventuellement lors d'une
contre-preuve des experts pour la
poursuite des traces et arnaud merci
beaucoup
richard dubé merci beaucoup forrest
fructifie à la prochaine